are you guys still um doing your
Festival in your hometown
we're gonna bring like um yes we gotta
bring it back and just revamp it like
make it even bigger this time like if I
remember one year you guys had Wayne and
it was it looked crazy yeah jumping big
it was just
definitely when we revamp it because we
took the time off so it's like now we
come back we gotta make sure we're doing
it even bigger and better like and we
had Kobe we had a lot of [__] yeah
exactly that's what I'm saying we come
back because Kobe like hey stop the
motion I don't it's the papers you know
what I'm saying I got a hammer a little
bit of grovel oh yeah so that's that's
just that's just you know you're just a
grab a guy then just that's what it is
even this right here there's a little
horse right here but I could do this
though you did what I'm saying I just
got the key for it and stuff yeah I
should have Mount Your Face Off for sure
that's why I see them little strips
right there the gas ain't bad you guys
[__] with shrooms at all
[__] I was actually like the other day I
was just thinking like shrimp life
shrimp like like that could be one of
our logos because we ain't never really
had a logo yet bro one day bro it could
be like two shrooms you know we live in
Miami bro one day I was on the beach
bruh
tell the story let's talk about the
craziest trips we've had so bam I ate
this chocolate so bam is a magic
chocolate so bam I hate the chocolate
I'm chilling vibing then this magical
dude with long hair walks up and then he
got
some mushrooms and then he gives us some
real mushrooms like not the ones on the
chocolate wait who it's a magical dude
with long hair I was already tripping so
I was lit so go down uh we taking shots
we on shrooms this is a real guy no this
is a real God this is really happy so
bam didn't I got the shrooms everybody
was so hyped
so you had some of these yeah I got the
strong I got some of the real shrooms
yeah like that oh I didn't pop everybody
Smurf houses hey look hey look they like
everybody was so hyped they know nobody
want to do them so like so you did them
crazy time of the day is this it's like
two o'clock P.M two in the afternoon on
the beach in Miami random dude comes
through with some magic mushrooms and
you ate all of them I ate all of them so
we right down the street from the SLS
they got the crazy pool party so bam
I'm walking as I'm walking the walk just
get better and better it's like the air
is just more air it's more air
everything's really HD it just got real
so country music like yeah I'm like wow
and then I get to the pool party and
then it's like it's too many people it's
like I could feel everybody walking by I
had to get out the party but I know
probably people looking at me weird I
was like
then I had to dunk my head I just walked
out the point I didn't even say nothing
so bam
I go to my crib I start playing the game
I'm playing Elder ring so I'm playing
Elder in the game right there boy is
looking too crazy so I had to turn it
off I start going through my phone all
the the words is popping out the screen
it's like hey I'm tripping so bad I was
like I don't went to sleep I go to sleep
my dreams is way too Vivid I wake up
like I'm just tripping the whole night
like it was the craziest day the
craziest thing is when you're tripping
hard and you try to go to sleep you
don't go to sleep you just dive into
like it's like [__]
simulation dealing with crazy so I woke
up the next day right I'm like man glad
that's over drinking water I'm going
through my day everything normal pull up
on this bad Crazy Fine pretty girl right
Tanisha yeah we're gonna call her right
now
we chilling she like oh I got the best
weed ever like to roll that up you know
what I'm saying we chilling we vibing
she let her I hit the blunt
the room just started getting smaller
it's like it just started leaning in I'm
like I gotta step outside so I stepped
outside so I stepped outside I feel
better I go back inside I'm tripping
again so now I call my friend I said bro
I need an Uber
I need an Uber I don't know why I
couldn't call on my phone I didn't even
call it I need an Uber I'd have ran to
the to the uh to the tire shop and I'm
sitting in front of the tire shop
waiting on the car these girls was
tripping they thought they did something
wrong they texting my phone like is
everything okay what did I do did I say
something yeah I didn't even notice I
didn't say nothing until I just walked
out and took off running I'm walking I'm
running down the street like this
imagine you're getting your tire changed
you look over and Slim Jimmy from race
rumors just sitting there tripping balls
like the [__]
gotta get an Uber man on the way home
like like I said I'm never doing that
again but like that was an eighth of
shrooms and that was like the craziest
yeah you ate the whole eighth yeah yeah
that's a serious amount buddy yeah what
about you what's the worst trip you've
had
man I ain't gonna lie I can't tell my
worst experience but I can tell like one
of the things I like happened like
like that you got to do like if you
tripping like you just gotta like hang
on I looked in the mirror like one time
like after I came home I was on the
shrooms I just looked at myself in the
mirror
like I was seeing myself like how
another person seen me or something like
you know what I'm saying like from
another person's eyes like [__] like I
was like damn that's what I look like
like
and it just like I just came to a
realization like like damn like that's
what girls see like when they look at me
and stuff like it was it was crazy
but this one time like we when I first
did them like when we first like like
shrimp like shrimp life like we was
living in Atlanta and stuff like me and
Jay actually did like my DJ right uh
right there
like random girls like they just like
liked our music we told them to go in
the studio like they came with us like
it was like two or three of them but we
were sitting on the couch like
boom we did the shrooms like boom all of
us did them like when we recording and
stuff like he was with his actually yeah
boom because he was in the booth he
started rapping about some crazy deep
stuff he like nobody loves me everybody
today
life isn't probably honest type of [__]
like don't listen to that life isn't
promised why are we here I just want to
be like I'm like yo hey yo I'm on this
road so then everything started changing
like boom like so the girls they was
next to me they was looking like they
started asking me a question I'm trying
to write my verses I'm listening to the
beat like I'm focused still like even
the show I'm just on a Vibe like then
they start asking like why aren't you
talking to us like why aren't you
showing me any attention like well I'm
like I'm just I've been chilling like
and they start asking in my head I'm
thinking I'm like and then they're like
they asked me like literally why don't
you love me like why don't you love us
like they're on the show too so I'm like
I'm understanding like okay this [__]
crazy like so wild thing to ask somebody
yeah they asked like why don't you love
them I'm like I love everybody like I'm
you know what I'm saying I'm like I'm a
down-to-earth [__] like but they kept
just like talking to me I had to just
like walk away and just like lay under
the piano and I was just like getting
away from everybody just laying on the
piano like Jesus what's worse though is
it the weed edibles or the shrooms
because I think we're doing it this is a
crazy story bro one time all right that
was one time I did this room by myself
when I over over did the strong but one
time I was on a boat with sway we on the
boat we're in the middle of the ocean
either had me some shrooms we got 30
girls on the boat we're in the middle of
the ocean it's a good allegedly right
right but right before I take these
rooms I'm in there dancing because I be
dancing so I'm in there like this you
know what I'm saying so then I take the
shrooms I start crying bro I don't know
what was wrong I don't went to the front
of the boat everybody like where's Jimmy
at where's Jimmy at I'm in the boat
right now
what's going on why was it I ain't never
even told somebody because I ain't that
everybody thought they did something
wrong they ain't doing nothing wrong no
I was good I think I think I think I
think I was in tune with the universe or
something yeah it was crazy I've had
that happen where I've been at the club
shrooming and then I just looked at my
boy and I was like bro I [__] love
you bro no like you're my brother I
[__] love you like and I started
crying I'm like I want you know I
appreciate you bro and he's like what's
wrong with you I'm like I just love you
dog like I appreciate your friendship
you know what I'm saying now you want to
compliment people and [__] no but we if
you eat weed it's way worse it's way
worse that [__] you just I don't like it
you don't know how you don't know how
that's gonna like react to you like your
body gonna react to that like it could
kick in you just be super sluggish
yeah like it tastes good I'm gonna eat
I'm gonna eat it like some candy and
then I'm gonna be asleep for two days
you guys should do a whole album just a
week in the middle of like Costa Rica
shrooming the whole time and just called
shroom life not for real mixtape
what's the best music to trip to
one more time
oh yeah that's a good one that is a good
one you guys ever listen to Tame Impala
huh a Tame Impala on the shrews man I'm
gonna tell you a better one than that
man this song right here this one is one
song I got
oh oh what's that one song that one song
be lit I ain't gonna lie I'm a Rocket
Man
this jump right here this one right here
playing a caravan
there's a plan no
okay are you be having them emotional
trips no no you just feel like hey hey
it's like damn what is life like yeah
this is really where we're at like in
life like we're gonna sleep I'm like
damn like this shit's simple like life
is so simple like
Mac Miller's got some great true music
too
I got I'm gonna show you what I'll be
tripping to y'all gonna laugh it's the
best song
oh this is great this is crazy like you
just feel like you like floating this
guy you can listen to this song in Miami
listen to the [__] EDM hey you can
listen to the song You're not high too
you only got to be hiding this in this
[__] like
this this guy's got the playlist on Deck
lots of [__] not probably not gonna play
bro
we're just gonna let it go
we live right now
uh let me show you what we got
oh look at this
[Music]
he got them crazy Liz
Ard the Avatar who's that my boy John
John
we're in the middle of an interview John
I said show you that man we're going
live right now
you already know the man himself I see
the boy in Miami yeah sirsky won't you
guys uh move to Miami
I move there
I moved there before I actually moved
there like before I even had a place
that I really moved there before I even
moved there but physically moved there
like a year and a half ago like I got a
condo down there and stuff on a
brickwell
you know what I'm saying it's tax free
it's actually God damn volume a lot of
[__] I'm trying to figure out why my
music wasn't playing bro I had to make
sure he's over here troubleshooting all
right is that the song hold up hold up
hold up I'm about to hit my damn real
quick hold up
okay
[Music]
with the lights with the lights
at the beginning of a movie or something
no that's what I'll be doing that's your
joint
I'm really a troll bro I can't do it if
you do scrolls with me you're gonna be
laughing the whole time because I'm
really a troll so both of y'all are in
Miami now yeah we both in Miami yet okay
how do you guys I mean I know you guys
are awesome he moved me to land because
he was down there having a good air time
every day and I was in Atlanta working
out working hard it is the thing that's
why he moving like it's tax-free like so
no state tax exactly because you guys
were in L.A exactly so I was making you
know you're making a lot of money but
it's you give them half your money to
Uncle Sam you have your money away give
it half your money to Joe Biden for him
to send that [__] over to another
country and you know what I'm saying Joe
Byron Joe Byron hey at least Ukraine
straight right young guy